soleil mer calme et rires d'enfants rien
ne semblait pouvoir bouleverser cet
après midi sur la plage du bord de shell
cher rien jusqu'à cette macabre
découverte par deux adolescents qui
s'adonnait à la plongée l arrivée en
courant était essoufflé et en fait elle
m'a dit un monsieur qui est sous l'eau
alors j'ai dit mais vous faites une
blague non monsieur sous l'eau et s'est
mis à pleurer et
et apparemment va du coup j'ai pas pour
vérifier je me suis dit et se sont
trompés il ya des vêtements sous l'eau
ou quelque chose et j'ai envoyé mon
conjoint qui a pris le masque et j tu me
fais ici c'est vraiment c'est ça il ya
été il m'a fallu six m'a dit c'est bon
j'étais vierge et était bien au fond
c'est un homme d'une cinquantaine
d'années près d'une cinquantaine
d'années ouais bonneil je pense qu'ils
aient de la plongée y nager et puis je
sais pas rater crise cardiaque
c'est pas mal aise ouais c'est pour la
famille une fois la présence du corps
confirmé un périmètre est érigée par la
gendarmerie
très rapidement le véhicule de secours
des pompiers laissent la place à celui
des pompes funèbres
la brigade nautique du marais un chargé
de récupérer le corps après avoir
réalisé les premières constatations sous
marine un drame qui interpelle les
nombreux touristes et riverains présents
énormément me fait pas défaut et ça fait
plus de 50 ans on n'a pas trouvé de
loyer là haut c'est cette page il a une
enquête est ouverte
il s'agira maintenant d'établir
l'identité de la victime et
éventuellement les circonstances de son
décès